thanks so much for having me
so yes I came in town for the first for
the trust conference which was Tuesday
and Wednesday it was a whole bunch of
Industry researchers over at the
Sheraton and there's like 10 of us
academics and they're all talking about
how great the trust and safety movement
is
um you know at meta and Tick Tock and
things like that and then today and
yesterday where the research Association
and I kind of felt like I was just
observing all these industry folks who
are talking about social media but from
the industry perspective so it's very
nice to be back with a classroom and my
academic peers
um
so the past couple years I started
feeling kind of
uh some frustration or uncertainty
around the ability of design and
Computing to address some of the big
social problems we see online so a
misinformation harassment hate speech
threats to democracy and so I started
looking into the law and so I was
looking at Tech policy regulation
criminal legal systems and then I
learned they don't know how to solve
these problems either but so now I'm
kind of taking this perspective that
Bridges Computing design social norms
and Regulatory considerations into how
should we think about designing studying
understanding regulating Tech broadly so
that'll be a theme through the talk
um so this semester I'm teaching two
classes at Michigan as it turns out one
is a PhD class it's called algorithms
discrimination and Justice and then I'm
also teaching a law class so basically
cosplaying a lawyer I don't have any
legal background but I was interested in
it so I said we're gonna really do this
and this is a tech lawn Society class so
I have law students and then me we kind
of meet in the middle and a major theme
in both of these courses
um is the idea that technology doesn't
create social inequalities but it can
reinforce or even magnify social
inequalities and so there should be this
responsibility to understand when that
happens and what do we do about it
that's been a major theme in research
and in teaching
so the talk today and a lot of my work
has focused on people and groups who are
sometimes overlooked or not sufficiently
addressed in the design of computing
systems okay and that's what I wanted to
pull out in the talk today I'm going to
cover a whole bunch of studies that my
group has done my PhD students I'm not
going to focus in detail on any given
study or the methods but more what are
some of the bigger ideas or findings
that we should care about when we think
about Overlook social groups and their
experiences
so just some context for me like I said
I'm a faculty School of information
adjunct at the law school right now as
part of this policy interest I'm a
fellow at the center for democracy and
Technology they do a lot of translation
Computing and design into policy work
um and also the Yale ISP and Justice
laboratory who are thinking about
similar intersections these are funding
sources as disclosures I'm a consultant
with the Twitter bird watch team which
is trying to address misinformation
online on a large scale so I'd meet with
them periodically and the work will talk
about benefits from wonderful
relationships with students and
collaborators
okay someone talk about two big themes
today one is social media governance how
do you decide who gets to say what
online
and then the second is deceptive
patterns or maybe dark patterns if you
know that term and profiling which is
how do you design
um
or how do you think about online
experiences and users and their right to
make choices consent to what they're
experiencing online so like I said I
decided not to organize this talk around
you know two or three studies but more
principles and ideas that I think we
should care about so I'll kind of move
through lots of different studies
um
in law there's this idea of normativity
it's basically saying what should we do
and I think that we could benefit to
bring some more of that into Computing
and design which is not so much can we
do this thing but also should we do this
thing
so
um let's start with social media
governance
so this is a graph I made and this is
basically mapping the experiments the
experience of how social media content
is moderated online anything you post
what happens to it so there's
everything's automated you know
everything that goes through for the
most part a social media platform so
Tick Tock Discord Twitter meta whatever
goes through automated filters and
that's to detect things like child
sexual abuse
extreme violence things like that
automated filters spam of course are
pretty good at detecting some of those
things like spam for right you don't see
a lot of spam on Twitter we're good at
that most content you know we'll get
through outside of those categories the
other way to flag something in a system
is if a user reports it so hey someone's
harassing me someone's harassing my
friend right you may be aware of the
reporting systems on sites and then it
goes into this convoluted process
um where there may be a worker review
and content moderators it was really
fascinating I was on the panel yesterday
at the conference and two of the other
panelists or speakers were working at
companies that hire the content
moderators who do this work and they're
really trying to like Market it as like
good for them like their well-being but
these workers are typically underpaid
third-party
um
companies so that the workers aren't
going to pay they're working at these
third-party companies often in the
Philippines or in India the company
yesterday was based in India and they go
through
a thousand posts this is what I learned
yesterday they put up slide not sure
they should have disclosed that but they
did it said confidential on the bottom
but
decide just let that go but
um so a worker is reviewing thousands
about a thousand posts a day um so every
20 30 seconds it's the bad stuff it's
not just like hey how you doing because
that doesn't go into the system it's
horrible stuff and
um some of it's traumatizing and all
these things so anyway this is the state
of how social media is governed is that
workers have to decide does it violate
some set of guidelines or does it not if
it does not then
um it just nothing happens if there was
someone who reported it they'll get a
notification saying this didn't violate
Community guidelines
um if it does get violated typically the
person who posted it will get some
notification if it's very extreme the
post may be taken down more likely
they'll get the warning there's a series
of kind of incremental sanctions
um last night I was talking to someone
who works at Discord and they apparently
have this complex interesting set of
responses that's much more nuanced than
this so I do feel like I need to update
a little bit about what actually happens
when you violate Community guidelines
but that'll be a theme in this talk
so let's focus on the top left the
automated flag how does this work as it
turns out Google puts perspective API
available online so most of the time we
don't know these are black boxes these
machine learning models and they're
basically saying take some content and
from zero to one can you predict how
toxic it is right and so you can try it
out you can download their system and
little API it's very easy to do it's
reasonable class activity and put text
in and say How likely is this to be
toxic right so this is just language
models so I put in Ann Arbor is the
worst Michigan and it gave a value of
0.5 so like on a scale of zero to one
about 0.5 that like this is a toxic
thing to say right
I also tried San Francisco is the worst
and it was like the same 0.5 is toxicity
I tried Palo Alto is the worst and it's
0.3 which means it's less toxic to say
Palo Alto is the worst we don't know why
that's in the model but this is all from
data somewhere
I also thought can we try I hate Google
to see if it's like self-reflexive right
this is a Google Google product
um
and that was 0.65 it's a little higher
like the word hate is going to trigger
you know probably higher um
and I tried I hit Microsoft which is
also 0.65 about the same I tried I hate
Facebook and that is again Lower it's
okay to hate Facebook and Palo Alto
turns out according to this Google but a
couple months ago there was this paper
from Google also and doing these these
language models which is not my
expertise but I think this part is
relevant here and they had 540 billion
parameters in this model to try to see
like how good can we get at detecting
things automatically
um
and even here there's variance this was
an example of like religion trying to
detect how toxic different statements
about religion are there's a huge amount
of variants it's just a hard problem and
so the key Point here is machine
learning is necessary and helpful for
detecting harmful content online but
it's not sufficient right there's going
to be errors false positive false
negatives
so I was interested in kind of user
understandings of how do they see
content as harmful or not harmful and
what would they want to happen when they
experience online harassment so these
are the studies I'm going to tell you
about
so let's start with the First theme
designing for the global majority
non-western different labels so most
tech not tech companies of course are in
the um here basically employing workers
here
um not necessarily representative of the
world's population that's a big problem
whether it's language or whether it's
understanding the cultures of different
communities
um this is a challenge and so we said
um how can we better understand content
moderation social media governance in
other regions around the world and the
companies itself like Facebook example
is explicit about the fact that it
focuses on areas of Interest areas of
priority so if even Facebook workers
file a
like a claim for inauthentic Behavior
this is the turnaround time that they
reported for how often how quickly they
will get to addressing that claim so
um even the US it's not so fast but a
couple days up there and then down
Mexico Honduras Azerbaijan is 300 and
400 Days see five complaint once this
came out presumably they're going to
address this but basically they sent her
U.S populations English-speaking
populations and things like that
so what this was a survey we did in 14
different regions around the world where
we asked about perceptions of harm of
different social media harassment types
and then preferred remedies and we
focused on regions that were overlooked
typically in social media governance so
things like places like Cameroon
Cambodia Malaysia Mongolia were part of
this study as one kind of principled
approach we decided to have people on
the team on This research team who were
from the regions that we studied so we
had at least one person from the 14
regions
so we asked him about different
harassment types these had to be kind of
globally relevant and able to be
translated into 10 different languages
across the different countries we
studied then so one was spreading
malicious rumors about you taking sexual
photos of you without your permission
sharing them on social media is often
known as non-consensual image sharing
now insults and rumors and then creating
fake accounts and sending you
um Melissa's malicious messages and we
asked about harm measures so
psychological harm personal safety
sexual harassment and family reputation
then we asked what would you want to do
in response to this right so removing
content being users
okay
so here's what we found
let me go over this do we lose okay uh
this was sexual photos so this was
sharing uh sexual content without your
permission non-consensual image sharing
huge issue globally there's very little
regulation at any federal or government
uh National level to address this big
problem
um and here you know the harm is very
high so on scale one to five it was five
of the highest harm one is lowest and
the blue dots reflect gender we weren't
looking explicitly agenda but we'd asked
gender as part of the survey women
perceive higher harm than men across the
board for these well actually you'll see
it for all of the different kinds but
the light blue dots are women and the
dark blue dots are men the next one
similarly you see malicious messages
it's lower than the sexual a
non-consensual image sharing harassment
type which is not surprising that's kind
of perceived as one of the worst kinds
of harm is to take someone's nude photo
without their consent and post it on the
internet where it cannot be contained
right
um
spreading rumors we're going to come
back to this one this is interesting but
a little bit lower in harm and there's
some variance family reputation is a
little bit higher right in terms of the
type of harm that's more prominent for
spreading rumors about people maybe that
makes sense and then insults and
disrespect was the lowest right so these
were overall perceptions of harm
globally or across 14 different regions
we also looked at across each region
what was the perceptions of harm and
I'll just focus on some key highlights
remember these are all like averages and
so we want to take them with a large
grain of salt everyone's different
within countries and across countries
things like that here United States was
lowest perception of harm right so we
think about if the United States is
making all these decisions about what
companies should do we're not
representative of the other countries
the highest was Colombia India Malaysia
Korea
so let me show you an individual plot
um for insults right and then for family
reputation reputational harm we saw the
biggest gap between the U.S and how they
people in the U.S perceive harm
and then other countries so India's
highest Malaysia China and so this is
because something like insults if you're
in the U.S maybe you're like okay of all
the bad things that can happen that may
be lower in perceived harm and family
reputation in the U.S is also not a for
many people a prominent like risk or
something that really you know keeps us
up at night in other regions it is both
insults are perceived as higher in harm
and also family reputation thrust to
family reputation these are especially
gendered as well there's a variety of
qualitative researchers nithya Samba
visan and Amna batul
um who've done kind of deep Dives in
regions like India and Pakistan where
there is family reputation there's honor
systems and where it's gendered where
being online and posting photos online
Etc is going to be high in harm in these
kinds of things Korea as well um lots of
lots of places
okay I'm going to switch to the next big
theme here uh justice Frameworks so I've
been thinking a lot about like I said
the criminal legal system and ideas
around punishment so if you post
something that you shouldn't on social
media what should happen nothing about
anything if you
cheat on exam if you steal something if
your kid hits their sibling for example
right what should you do should you
punish them how do you try to
rehabilitate them and so I've been
thinking about how should social media
platforms do this right
um
and so I'm going to bring two fields in
conversation together here
um and this is the criminal justice
system which is we punish people if
you're interested in policing this is a
big topic right now is policing is not
initially rehabilitative and it's
harmful for lots of people there's
Alternatives like restorative justice
which say
um just pull it right up
um who has been harmed and what do they
need
and so there's lots of restorative
justice movements for example there's
across regions and historically there's
lots of restorative justice efforts but
Stanford itself the student office has a
restorative justice option if there's
interpersonal conflict or harm there's
lots of different steps one can take but
one option is restorative justice which
is thinking about can you apologize can
you have mediation can you have some
alternative way of responding to the
harm
so we were interested in this question
when people experience harassment could
you try or would people be interested in
different kinds of responses right
um and so we did the study in the US and
this was with 570 something adults we
oversampled by gender and race so we
oversample people who were non-binary
and transgender and then people who were
Black latinx Or Hispanic Asian
um
and Native American indigenous
so let me jump right to the results here
this is preferences for these remedies
okay so abandoning user is still the
most popular like that's what happens
and so like we're punitive we like to if
someone harasses you just ban them
um what was interesting with this this
is how much uh you know the y-axis is
how much people prefer these various
remedies
um apology was next so that was a little
bit surprising that's obviously not
something that's like people are not
particularly good apologies in general
but sometimes to resolve harm or resolve
a conflict that might be the right way
to go
um
a fender list was like public shaming
basically so this is not typically
encouraged and like most legal systems
these days is like
violates people's right to dignity and
lots of things but if you're online you
know this is known colloquia's culture
or cancel culture right people support
this as a way to respond to perceived
harms or experienced harms on social
media sites right so people like this
that's why why we see it but
um
content removal those other ones here
like educating people about their
identity with more like a remediation
kind of conflict remediation strategy
um having your own space as well payment
was an interesting one so it's kind of
like uh on Instagram you could imagine
could you kind of compensate people if
they experience harassment and it sounds
far-fetched but I mentioned it to some
of the industry folks last night and
they're like yeah that's within the
scope of around what we might imagine
mediation people didn't like
manipulating audience sizes this is
Shadow Banning for example right which
because it's mostly not transparent what
happens right so
um and a lot of people have claimed that
their Shadow band which means they post
stuff and no one sees it and they feel
like the algorithms are
deflating making it not appear in news
feeds so
here's some variances in terms of what
people want to see happen
we also asked about this for the 14
region the global study so this is
across the 4 000 or so participants
across 14 regions around the world here
we see apologies a little bit lower in
terms of favorability we asked a
narrower category of options still
removing and banning is still the two
most popular across the different
types of harassment we still see that
women are more positive than men about
most of these but the Gap is smaller so
in terms of Remedies one key point is
that all of these are higher than
neutral basically people want something
to happen like you know the experience
harassment they'll take anything like
give me something you know that was my
interpretation of this one interesting
one was payment we saw a reversal of
gender the very bottom one so women are
less favorable about the idea of payment
than men maybe because they see this as
a Band-Aid that's like overlooking their
experiences or something like that we
don't know why
all right we also asked young people
about what would they like to see happen
so this is just a simulation but we sent
them this was we sent text messages to
over 800 young people 14 to 24 in the US
only
um you know using an automated system so
basically sent them a text message once
they responded it sent the text message
the next text message back
and so the question we asked them was
what would you want to happen or what
would you feel like a fair resolution
resolution to you if you experience
following your harassment we thought a
lot about language and like tested in
all these things for young people
bullying is more Salient as you get
older it's harassment so we use both
they could choose kind of how to think
about it
any guesses on what they might like to
see
um content removal Banning Social
support from Friends apologies
what do you think young people wanted
social Port yeah
apologies
apologies yeah I mean they they also
like all of them but uh yeah yeah take
anything but it was pretty uh
overwhelming support for private
apologies so 60 preferred the apology
and of those twice as many preferred
private apology this is probably because
a lot of their conflict is going to be
interpersonal there's long-standing
social relationships if they're in high
school right it might be within that
Community they don't want drama they
don't want parents in schools getting
involved because that usually makes
sometimes makes things worse
um and so private apology I think that's
important because we think about
designing online systems social media
governance on a very large scale young
people may need very different responses
or benefit from very different responses
than adults right do you think that's
because of that stage of being young and
those issues with parents or is that
that generation is going to be different
as they age they'll still want something
like that that's a good question I would
guess it's something to do with being
young
um just
young people don't trust most we also
asked them about how much do you trust
companies to like respond fairly to
issues you experience and it was very
low but yeah I think it's a I think it's
a persistent characteristic of young
people not to trust institutions around
them right whether it's parents in
schools and
um and so I guess it's stable but yeah I
don't know
good question
um some of the things they said there
needs to be deleted posts um private
apology this last one I like because
like you asked young people on text
message they'll say what they really
think
um stopping a little [ __ ]
um which is what they want right it's
like no drama just stop move on okay
uh this was funny so for the folks to
study con this was funny to me I don't
know we'll see
um so I like went on some little website
here to I fake test matches to like
create this just for these slides and
then I saw that they created transcript
and they removed the word harassly they
like moderated the word harassed out of
their transcript because they thought it
was bad which is like the most naive
interpretation of moderating content
ever like the word harassment
oh they removed that someone want to go
on to ifaketextmessage.com and test
I'm serious Let's test if it's
s
things you'd never like imagined hey
students go text type an ass and see the
horse
um yeah so I guess this would be us as
well the other two I tried like a bunch
of them because I you know rabbit holes
some of them didn't moderate harass or
ass I hadn't even thought about that but
someone try and let us know what how it
works it's also extremely even more
naive if they're moderating out ass
without white space on either like
the class an intro CS class
maybe not this exact assignment but like
something like that
um
okay and then last uh theme I'm going to
focus on here is human rights and civil
rights for social media governance so um
come back to the slide I showed you and
in this we looked at specific groups
remember I said we oversampled people by
race and gender and so in a regressions
we pulled out do those groups fall out
as having different preferences than the
average right the whole point is like
we're trying to think about how groups
that are overlooked might experience
things so for example we saw that green
lines here the people are transgender
Native American Hispanic or latinx were
less favorable towards payment than the
average right maybe again they see this
as a Band-Aid overlooking their
experiences you know to pay them off or
something but we didn't ask but that's
one possible interpretation
people who are transgender also didn't
like the apology and I'm guessing that
maybe there's a sense of like if
someone's harassing them for being
transgender they don't want to have any
further communication with that person
apology or not right like so apologies
are limited in scope if someone's
harassing you like
they don't you don't owe them the
opportunity to apologize in my opinion
um and then Native American
um indigenous people were less favorable
towards Banning users which is
interesting you know these are beta
coefficients like this is reasonably
High we did see there are more positive
transgender people Native Americans and
Asians for identity maybe not
surprisingly this was educating people
about your identity as part of your
online experience right
so um
that's good let's keep going
um we also asked the young people we
that had oversampled by a variety of
criteria these were from transgender
participants who replied so we pulled
out transgender participants and looked
at again ran regressions to examples
they were less favorable towards the
apology than the average
um young person respondent so this was
830-something respondents so it was like
30 or 40 people who are transgender with
that caveat but they said things like
people who are asked me in high school
over my gender and sexual identity
social media doesn't do [ __ ] for
bullying when it came out as trans I was
harassed on Instagram Etc so the point I
want to emphasize again is one size fits
all approaches to how we govern social
media are going to fall short of
supporting people and especially maybe
some groups are already
faced challenges in their offline lives
um in this final study I'm going to just
keep brief but this was a qualitative
focus group study led by PhD student
Tyler Musgrave and she was interested in
black women's women and femmes
experiences of online harassment and so
what kinds of harassment did they
experience what does healing look like
for them
um how do they experience Joy and this
was an interesting method so she used
restorative justice techniques okay so I
remember I mentioned restorative justice
has a song history it's now in
Stanford's student body in Michigan's as
well and she said instead of taking like
a neutral objective interview or survey
approach you know we're going to keep
ourselves removed from this and just say
what do you think she said no
restorative justice says you have
experienced harm I'm going to recognize
that harm maybe I've shared that harm
with you and lead the focus group in
that way so it's using this pretty
different method that's not typically
used in HCI user experience industry but
I think it could be an important way to
recognize say some groups experiences
and like the Traditions that they might
care about
so I'm going to focus on just two themes
here they experience they talked about
harassment The Experience from white men
and women
then also harassment the experienced
from black men
so um just one some quotes here one said
I would get confronted a lot on
Instagram mostly white women men who I
knew in person aggressively disagree
with me why do black lives matter Etc
the second one was about experience of a
black man who was sexually harassing
this participant and he kept kind of
getting in DMs there's two themes that I
think are important here um
one is this concept of misogynoir if you
care about the intersections of race and
gender especially for black women
there's this book by Moya Bailey called
about
um misogynoir and there's also papers
now on like algorithmic misogynoir which
is the kind of unique harassment
experiences that black women
um experience the second one cultural
betrayal theory is a framework an idea
from Dr Jessica Gomez and this is
talking about the experience of betrayal
that is within groups within communities
who themselves experience
marginalization and Tyler is very clear
to say that this is not a critique of
black men for example it was more a
reflection of within communities how do
you resolve conflict or harm especially
when those communities are already
punished or harmed themselves within
society and we wrestle a lot with how to
write this paper for the kai audience so
Kai this conference it's like very white
black women's experiences are overlooked
in the conference as black men's and so
this is yet another example of many why
representation matters
okay I'm going to switch to the second
theme Here
dark patterns how many people know the
term dark patterns
you covered in class or
I guess the fact we raise our hands but
okay so these are patterns that mislead
or deceive people into doing something
online that they wouldn't otherwise have
done so if you've signed up for a
subscription model and you realize later
like they're still charging you and you
like didn't know that happened or you'll
kind of have an interface design you
think you're canceling but really you're
doing something else these are all
deceptive models that might change what
you are doing without your intention
this is a big theme now the FTC the
Federal Trade Commission is like really
looking into dark patterns as a thing
that they want to regulate so tell
companies if you do more of this dark
pattern mess we're going to come after
you and sue you we have a dark patterns
repository uh King right yeah yeah
awesome this way thank you for the
reminder I just talked to John yesterday
um
okay
so how many people looked at so I'm
going to talk about kind of different
kinds of dark patterns that might
manifest how many people looked at your
ad settings
what's the set all right
um Google probably
yeah well here's some links if you want
to look at Facebook and Twitter's as
well they all capture different things
maybe all different things and let you
manipulate different things okay has
anyone changed these settings in any way
yeah what did you do
yeah okay fair yeah yeah
um on Facebook I've been a man a
seven-year-old man since 2013 I was
pregnant with my first kid and I kept
getting all the weight loss and like
Muffin Top ads on Facebook so I was like
a 30s woman of course all we want to do
is Diet right and so I became a 70 year
old man I've like never gotten a weight
loss ad again in the last decade I did
get weird things like diaper ads which
was like I had kids but I was also an
older man yeah different kind of diaper
so anyway
um you can manipulate things because
you're not supposed to but you can't
um so I looked into kind of Facebook and
how do you actually kind of adjust
things so this was like one of my random
um kind of go into the ad targeted ad
profiling and you know who knows what
this is I don't play golf but I clicked
on golfnow.com in fact I explicitly
don't care about golf so I clicked on
this and it said like golf now
and then there's a wire included in this
advertiser's audience so I clicked on
that and then you have this thing and
you can say allow or don't allow you
know various I guess just don't allow
opt out of things so you can do this
like two or three hundred times you know
every week or two as it repopulates your
Facebook feed should you want to come
you know decide what ads you get
all right I'm going to skip through
these examples so this is a project led
by PhD student Kami Garay and she was
interested in how do young people
understand what ads they're being fed
and why right and so she interviewed
them and asked them about this and then
she had them pull up their Google ad
settings and say like what do you think
is this what you thought and then she
had them also
um categorize
targeting based on sensitive
characteristics like race age and gender
and how they perceive that useful or
creepy or both yeah
we thought this was important for a
couple reasons first of all young people
are tracked right we've already talked
about this tracked in a variety of ways
throughout their lives their education
systems their home systems policing
systems and prison systems and the way
they may be tracked through the
algorithmic experiences they have online
through the profiling is important and
not well understood I have a
nine-year-old boy and one of my biggest
questions is what kind of
misogynistic and white supremacist
content might be exposed to on YouTube
use free access to YouTube which is a
choice we made but like he could be
exposed to a lot of things so I think
this is a huge area that we should be
studying but this was with um young
people so we had the math on a mural
Board of useful to creepy and we took
the nine or so protected characteristics
uh eight or nine and said how useful is
this to you to be targeted based on your
age your race your gender Etc and then
how creepy is it right it turns out like
those are not mutually exclusive like
this is just one participant but
um there's a lot of things where it's
like both useful and also creepy and
they're kind of like well you know this
is weird but we're okay with this useful
because then we get stuff that's more
personalized to us
um so some of the findings here where
they were
Mo they were pretty certain they
understood that they were being targeted
based on their behavior so you click
like on something you can get an ad for
related content
um they understood on sites like Tick
Tock which is newer your scrolling
behavior is going to predict
they're going to infer based on what you
hover on what you might like anyone on
my Miami Boys Choir like super obsessed
with them right now
check it out Miami Boys Choir it's super
weird but like that is so popular but
anyway
um you hover on something it's gonna
just serve it right up to you on Tick
Tock what they didn't know about were
things like um
search history does that dictate ad
preferences or ad experiences they
didn't know about their social network
experiences does that shape what kind of
ads they see and then location-based
tracking right they didn't know that one
they had lots of folk theories or like
conspiracy you know ideas about what
might be happening one common one you've
probably heard of is are devices
listening to me and so
um you know like one time I spoke about
something it just popped up I was like
what that is weird it was one time I was
cooking I was mad hungry and there was
food I was like what that's crazy right
probably you've experienced this you had
a conversation and then I'll relate you
get an ad for some random thing you're
talking about and
I'm pretty sure everyone's saying audio
tracking is not a thing but I still am
skeptical so I'm right there with the
conspiracy theorist right like companies
are all saying we do not track your
audio and advertise based on this but
I don't know what do you guys think do
they do it we don't know there's other
cues that you don't know yeah yeah it's
all this so many other environmental
circumstantial cues locations
yeah yeah
I don't know I'm still gonna
we can have a few conspiracy theories
each side that's mine
okay the next study I have two more
studies and then we'll try to have a
little time for questions if you want
this took a consumer advocacy approach
um
to prioritize ethical design practices
in e-commerce experiences basically what
kind of agency do people have to consent
or decide what they buy online so this
was led by Carol Moser she did a
systematic content analysis of the top
200 e-commerce websites in the US and
looked at
um what kind of features they employ to
encourage impulse buying behaviors so
things like lowering perceived risk
discount promotion codes if you've ever
gone to hotels.com you know any
purchasing things is like there's like
seven other you know you can look at a
North Dakota hotel in January now and
like there's seven other people looking
at this hotel right now I'm like there's
not you know it's just we don't know how
they come up with this and it's not
regulated another FTC thing that people
care about
um so as after she did that first study
she looked at can you design
interventions to try to reduce impulse
buying behaviors so she built a Google
Chrome plug-in that introduced a time
delay between moving something into your
cart and then being able to purchase it
so take away the no buy now button right
like if you're on Amazon and on Amazon
just like impulse buy just get things
um and so she wanted to look at what
that shape behavior and so
um basically you can proceed to checkout
in one condition and you'll remove it
another and this was a lab experiment
it's a little hard to do this in the
wild um we originally wanted to do a
chrome plug-in that like could be just
used widely but it was hard to enforce
it basically people choose their devices
try to instrument intervene in people's
behavior and if it's do a phone
intervention they're going to get on
their browser and browser or anything on
the phone so we gave up
um
and then we also can uh so the we did a
lab experiment with 130 something
participants where they're given 20 to
spend so explicitly given 20 this is
common in like economics behavioral
economics to give something someone
something
um then they're not using their own
money and so and then some incentives to
buy things but we um so we discounted
products and then so there's incentive
to want to buy it because it's really
cheap right um you're given money and
it's cheap
and we had these different conditions
where we had the control and then we
created a 10 minute postponement to see
if it changed their buying behaviors and
about one-third of participants
purchased something that they did not
otherwise plan to which was not a high
amount so that may be why we didn't see
a difference here in terms of just the
10 minute postponement itself
and so she did another study and that
was lab-based and this was 700
participants and she created a mock-up
e-commerce site and measured purchase
intent so this time we didn't give them
20 it just became a little large scale
but this was an online experiment and
here she added a reflect uh reflection
period so not just a postponement but
she said one we're thinking about buying
things
select five reasons why you would want
to buy it and five reasons why you would
you not want to buy it now imagine doing
this every time you're about to buy
something like you have to reflect on
why do you want this or why don't you
want this
um and she also had a distraction
condition so this was just like click on
some things
um
and so here we see that both the
reflection and distraction prompt
significant substantially lowered and
significantly lowered um the urge to buy
something versus the control and so
maybe it's that just adding time doesn't
necessarily change people's behavior but
having them do something so either
distracting them cognitively or having
them actively reflect maybe you don't
need the whole reflection process but
something that takes them away from that
purchasing Behavior there may be some um
it was they were clicking on dots and it
was a little bit cognitively distracting
where you had to like count the dots
kind of a thing very inane game yeah
yeah so it's not just sitting there but
it's doing some task
yeah
um and so there's a key takeaway here is
that for HCI
and which is why I came into the kind of
this law of policy stuff um is that my
sense is that
some of these challenges put too much
burden on the user to control their own
behavior so we talk about user agency
and designing things that are easy to
use but things like manipulative
Behavior
subscription services that are deceptive
it's too hard for users to know what
they're consenting to and do they
actually want to consent to this right
so this is one of the reasons um
I think companies need to be more
principled in how they do this and
probably this is a call for regulation
because they're not going to do it
unless someone tells them you have to do
this so you have to stop doing the more
manipulative kind of behaviors online
okay and then the last one is a little
bit of a tangent but I like going to set
that and include it okay so imagine
you're walking through and you take this
beautiful photo and you want to share it
online
um now imagine you're also blind and low
vision so you're thinking about what was
in the photo was there anything that I
should or shouldn't share so you rely on
some apps that can help you you upload a
photo and say what's in this photo right
um and there's human and AI based apps
I'll talk about that in a minute so you
can this is Amazon recognition you can
create an account and use it and it says
there's grass plant outdoors lawn you
know lots of things it predicts it
doesn't get the buildings at all like it
just
the buildings are not labeled so it's
really focused on what's in the
Forefront
um I just did this like a few days ago
so this is pretty up to date on campus
yeah I think campus is the building
there's a roof
um
but yeah it's you know it's fairly
minimal theme and it's pretty
underspecified
um this is photoy stall of some Stanford
Graduate here we have person human
graduation you know all very accurate it
doesn't really have the Stanford
building the back doesn't at all have
the standard building the background
right
and this was I did this exercise in my
PhD class A student uploaded a photo of
their cat
when I did it in the class they said
that um
yeah well anyway I did it again a few
days ago so there's cat pet mammal
animal like yes those are all accurate
in the foreground like it's got the
boxes very confident about those but
then you get to couch plant
LCD screen Electronics which I think are
all wrong right so the background stuff
it's having a hard time with so the
question with all of these is you um you
know the foreground stuff is recognized
well and the background stuff is not and
so she was interested in this question
of obfuscation if you take a photo if a
blind or low vision person takes a photo
of something and maybe they know what's
in the foreground either because they
have an idea of it because of their
environment or their app can tell them
what's in the foreground
but they don't know what's in the
background what if there's something
private that they want to obfuscate to
not show so it could be uh their toilet
or like a picture of a naked bite or
whatever you know like if you don't know
and so
um she was interested in so she did an
interview study where she asked blind
low vision people
um who use apps like Microsoft seeing AI
which is AI powered me my eyes human
powered some of them are joint um
basically they label images for people
who are blind they do it quickly
um you can if you want to volunteer you
can join be my eyes and basically every
so often you get a call and say someone
just says like can you tell me what's in
the photo and you tell them right
um what do they want to have obfuscated
and how much do they trust AI kind of as
this thing to be able to tell them what
is in the background and with some
amount of accuracy right and so there we
she Drew on this idea of interdependence
as Cynthia Bennett and others have
talked about which is that they did not
want to trust the AI to
um entirely tell them what's in the
background because the confidence level
is low the human confidence level and
statistical constants or the machine
learning confidence level but they also
didn't want to like tell them everything
so they had to decide for themselves so
there's this concept of interdependence
where
just thought about like what would be
the kind of interaction where a blind or
low vision person could say give me some
prompts to help me understand what might
be in the background and how much
confidence I should have in that to make
a decision for myself about whether to
obfuscate it it's ethically questionable
because if something's super sensitive
like bank cards or naked bodies like
having the app look at that content is
already kind of a privacy violation so
to know to obfuscate it you have to know
what's in it right to be able to
obfuscate it
um anyway I think there's a lot of
future work here and also with audio
data same questions right um how do you
obfuscate stuff that's in the background
of noise data that's less
um well detected by Machine learning
okay so those were the
series of principles I want to talk
about and a whole bunch of studies
um
I think that I don't actually know what
I'm doing with my future work right
these days I'm just kind of in a holding
pattern so I'm not going to talk about
future work and I like to take questions
but I'd be happy to talk about things
I'm thinking about but in the future but
let's just go straight to questions we
have time for it thank you
[Applause]
a certain groups certain identities have
preferences for you know different harm
reduction methods more punitive methods
I'm curious if you see
um you know industry figures uh or the
people in charge of these systems
potentially implementing sort of
separate pipelines for for these
policies based on identity so for
instance if somebody's on
um you know Twitter or Facebook it
indicates in their profile like I'm
transgender and then Facebook says okay
we'll have a different you know punitive
pathway for you if you report or
something like that I'm curious if
that's what you don't approach that is
being talked about
um I talked about it this week to the
industry audiences um and actually Tom
Tyler colleague yeah there's a few
conversations
the biggest challenge when a huge design
interesting kind of HCI opportunity is
how to create more personalized
governance experiences that allow people
to make some decisions for themselves
about what pathway they want to take but
that's not overly paternalistic because
if you say oh you must apologize because
what we know you're identity like No
One's Gonna like that and that's a
harmful you know so it's like that
reduce risk while increasing benefits
and so I think it's about creating
Pathways that let people choose but they
can't be adjudicating the same way like
you don't have victims decide what
happens to an offender in the legal
system because victims May over be
overly punitive and things like that so
I think like yes there may be some
reception for kind of creating more
Pathways one principle that I think
everyone agrees on and just needs to
happen is transparency which is people
don't like governance Pathways in the
criminal legal system or on social media
if they don't understand why they're a
banned or why the content was removed or
why it wasn't removed and so being able
to say these are the sets of criteria we
used and let people know ahead of time
and then also retroactively people
aren't there's procedural justice theory
says people are more okay with outcomes
if they understand the process through
which one move to get to that outcome so
yeah
first of all thank you so much I really
enjoyed it I wanted to ask a bit more
about the dark patterns
um so how you know these companies can
subtly nudge users into behaviors they
might not be expecting
um I want to I was curious to hear more
about the sort of regulations that the
government can see as well as what sort
of Fine Line there is between something
that's just like a pro-business practice
maybe like the Amazon checkout button
versus a full-blown dark pattern yeah
it's a great question
um and there's not a clear line like
this is one this you know marketing is
somewhere between
all right like
um yeah so FDC is think it's um ramping
up its interest in misleading and
deceptive design patterns and I think
that they're going to do it by focusing
on the worst players and some worst
kinds of designs that are systematic and
large scale so something like
subscription models where they've
received numerous complaints to the
Better Business Bureau saying I'm being
charged sixty dollars to cancel this
thing and I didn't know when I signed up
that I have to pay 60 to cancel it or I
signed up for a week and I didn't know
that they kept charging me for the next
six months right and you have numerous
reports so a lot of it's like user you
know HCI like user generated like lots
of people complain about this company it
means they didn't understand the process
and it was there for misleading right so
I think that's
but it's kind of a ground up like
rather than kind of a policy down I
think it's trying to like look at
different companies and what are they
doing and which can they go after and
when lawsuit's against and then sort of
formalize some of those principles
um if you go to their website they have
lots of they've had some workshops and
stuff on Direct patterns so they have
one on Monday actually that I'm going to
but
yeah
Yeah
you mentioned that you've been on sort
of a journey over time and you're
thinking about how and to what extent
platforms should integrate restorative
justice into their policies I'm curious
could you just like sort of summarize
what that Journey was like were you like
where are you now and what's taking you
there yeah so I you know I got the
restorative justice um that was just a
side interest or concern with uh
policing criminal legal systems clearly
like they're they're not working in
there too many people are imprisoned in
our country for not good reasons right
um so that was just kind of like looking
at that and so I learned about
restorative justice and so I got pretty
excited about that for a while and then
I came back and I was like no actually
I'm good with punishing people there's a
lot of terrible people on the internet
like we can punish them
um I think it kind of led to me to a
more um
an idea of differentiating different
kinds of experiences so think about like
your interpersonal relationships or your
parenting relationships or teaching if
someone
makes a mistake or causes harm we don't
give them the same response we don't
always punish them or we don't always
just say apologize I'll be better like
you think about what's appropriate for
that context earn for that person that
child that relationship and so it kind
of just
I was sort of like we're punishing too
many people but that's in the criminal
legal system but it does come up online
and people are being
um overly sanctioned or Shadow van like
sex workers for example if they were
overly sanctioned for non-legal content
because they post various photos like
there can be harm for some groups so
yeah now I'm like I like the restorative
justice thing but but just a little bit
right like there's some pretty terrible
people and content I think we still need
like device level bands IP level bands
but for all the people who are not
trying to be terrible and who just knew
the rules or had a chance to say hey I'm
sorry I won't do that again like don't
put them in the punitive pipeline give
them a more restorative Pipeline and
actually that's the majority of people
it's not the majority of harm but it's
the majority of people that's in the
pretty well known at companies and do
you ever respond like if the response is
like oh I don't know how that scales one
of those kinds of things yeah
he made the vision for us to how that
would work yeah yeah so how does a scale
I think you can build restorative
pipelines into interface designs right
which is what kinds of things do people
want you can just say like did you
intend to do this do you think you're
going to do this again and let people
say no I'm not gonna do this again
because you can measure it do they do it
again and like did they uphold their
agreement so you can automate those
things I also think the question of
scale comes up a lot with restorative
justice like it how does this scale I'm
like but the punitive justice system
doesn't scale either unless you accept
that like millions and millions of
people in prisons every day is like an
acceptable society live in which I don't
so neither of them scale right
uh time for one more question I think
good
um so thinking about uh governance again
on social media um obviously like a big
part of the whole consideration has to
be the fact that people can't just make
a new account
um or you know even a bot Network
harassment so I'm curious
um if if you know that people have
different uh perceptions on
um on what should be done or what what
their preferred thing would be say if
it's an individual that they know who
says something hateful about them versus
you know I'm being targeted by a boss
man or something like that
yeah I think that there need to be
better protections and escalations for
people who are being systematically
targeted by networked harassment right
so network does lots of people have gone
online decided to harass this one person
this is what Kiwi Farms does right kiwi
Farms is now taken down and trying to
find someone to host them because their
whole existence is to take people and
usually like disabled or transgender
people and collectively harass them in
those cases I think those people who are
being harassed need better protections
from the companies like it's not hard to
know those people aren't being harassed
like anyone can look at it you can see
it algorithmically so so yeah I think
it's allowing people who are
experiencing harm to have more agency
and what happens to them right now it's
like you block or you don't what are you
going to block thousands of people all
the time there needs to be like more
sophisticated
ways to protect yourself and the
companies should be responsible for
supporting that in addition to like
dealing with the networked harassment
but
it's a good question it's a huge problem
all right okay why don't we cut here
thank you Sarita thank you